باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي غير محتال صيني
شكله وانتحل شخصيه صديق رجل اعمال لينتزع
منه اكثر من نصف مليون يورو وفقه وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه الضحيه اوضح انه تلقى في
ابريل مكالمه عبر الفيديو من شخص بدا
شبيها شكلا وصوتا باحد اقاربه واخبره
بحاجته الى مبلغ من المال
لكن الذي كان يتحدث معه كان في الواقع
محتالا استخدمت تقنيه ذكاء الاصطناعي
لتعديل ملامح نجح في اقناع رجل الاعمال
بتحويل 600 الف دولار من الحساب المصرفي
لشركه وبعدما حول رجل الاعمال المبلغ بعث
برساله الى صديقه الذي انتحلت هويته طبعا
وطبعا عندما ادرك الخطا الذي اقترفه
ارسلته
مصرف بوقف عمليه تحويل من استرداد 485 الف
دولار فيما لم يتم او لم يتم التوصل بعد
لهويه المسؤول عن عمليه الاحتيال بس والله
رجل الاعمال هذا كريم جدا ومساعد لاقاربه
يعني يا ريت كان قريب هدفينا ما راحت
فلوسك يا صابر
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات